okay
so
uh i'm not going to talk about mechanics
design i think maybe the last talk in
this conference will which is not going
to be on mechanics design perhaps i'm
not sure but uh
on the other hand this talk let me tell
you something about the history of that
it started in fact from my first time
being a dutch tool where i think
christos talked about some complexity of
nash equilibrium hardness exactly i
guess the day and then i had the same
reaction as ilia had yesterday what
about correlated equilibria they say oh
that's clear okay well tell us not to be
clear and then i kept asking
my friends in computer science in fact
in the year that noam and mikhail
organized in jerusalem i proposed this
as a problem in during the one of the
panels or something and everybody said
it's a very good problem but
nobody gave me an answer so at the end i
told the noam look
this problem can't stay unsolved we have
to have to handle it and we did it so
now i'm going to tell you what happens
so
first of all there is a paper
which you can find on my web page now
i'm assuming that you know what the
correlated equilibrium is but it doesn't
really matter
okay
what will matter for the talk is the
following thing so for simplicity we are
going to take
uh
simple games simple games are end person
games where every player is just two
strategies okay or actions it's called
says actions here but two strategies
okay simple uh
in the end uh as i say it's for whatever
two you want you means replace two by m
where m is the number of strategies and
everything will go through okay but
let's talk about two so a correlated
equilibrium
is defined by
a probability distribution each cell
each
n tuple of actions as what they call a
cell you have a probability so there are
two to the power n unknowns which are
non-negative and add up to one
and there are constraints now because
everybody has just two strategies for
those that know correlated equilibria it
says when you are supposed to play
strategy one you prefer it to switching
to strategy two and you are supposed to
play strategy two you prefer it to
switching to strategy one those are just
two constraints so in total you have two
n plus one constraints which are linear
everything is linear so it's a very
simple problem
2 to the power n unknowns 2 n plus 1
linear inequalities what could be easier
than that yes very easy so linear
programming we know there is an
algorithm for computing a correlated
equilibrium whose complexity is
polynomial in in
unfortunately 2 to the power n which
makes it exponential in n
okay
so far so good
now
but
now comes the but
okay
there are dynamics which in fact ever
mentioned
in the previous talk and have been here
there are great base dynamics
where you can
allow those dynamics for players playing
the game but of course any dynamic we
can emulate computer scientists emulate
everything so they can emulate dynamics
by emulating everything that all the
players do and so you get an algorithm
out of a dynamic
and we get
approximate call it equilibria with high
probability
and how long does it take
extremely fast
log n over epsilon square steps
now remember we're in a place where data
is 2 to the power n
so turns out that the number of steps it
takes by the way the estimation of the
number of steps is due to cesar bianchi
and lugosi
the estimation of the number of steps
sorry the the number of steps it takes
log n of the order of log n remember
it's to the power n so it's double
exponential reduction which is quite
amazing in retrospect okay
so now
the way we want to measure
since you don't want to get into issues
of how many computations you make anyway
the computations made here at every step
are trivial you just add some a bunch of
numbers and you take ratios there is
nothing you don't compute fixed points
or any such fancy things it's very
trivial but the way that we are going to
measure it is is by the thing called
query complexity which is how many
queries on the data of the problem
the algorithm makes and the query means
we look at the cell namely one of the
two to the power n
action combinations and ask what is the
payoff of player two there what is the
payoff of player 1 there so the total
data we have to do power n cells in each
one we have n numbers the pairs of the n
players so there are n times to the
power n
possible
data point data
not points data
what they call it
pieces pieces pieces of data
yes
and so no just so that we calibrate
and so we ask how many queries out of
those they are going to makes so it
turns out that the fact that the number
of steps is log n over epsilon square
but each one of the players has to do
something so you have to multiply it by
n or maybe by n square anyway it's
polynomial in l okay that's what we care
so
conclusion there are randomized
algorithms for finding approximate
correlated equilibria whose query
complexity is polynomial in n
remember linear programming says
everything is exponentially n
okay now is it a surprise
well shouldn't be much of a surprise
because think about it first of all we
know there are correlated equilibria
whose support is of size two n plus one
because we have two n plus one
inequalities so basic solution has
supported two n plus one so in principle
the fact that you know uh
we find something like this quickly
should be a surprise
then uh so that's one non-surprise uh
factor the other is that if we use the
lipton and young result
that talks about
how big this which i think in this
community everybody knows about
there is someone who doesn't know about
it
oh okay good so
i didn't know about it until a couple of
years ago uh
so
this says this asks the following
question suppose i have a two-person
zero-sum game
okay i'm player one and there is player
two suppose player 2 has m strategies
i have many more strategies than them
let's say
how many strategies do i need
to play with positive probability in
order to guarantee that i'll find an
optimal strategy answer very easy m so
in order to
optimal to find an optimal strategy when
the other players m strategies i also
need to use m strategies
now how many strategies do i need to use
if i want to find an epsilon optimal
strategy
the answer is log m over epsilon square
at osm constants which are two or four
or whatever we don't care about those
okay so to find an optimal strategy i
need the support to be as large as the
number of strategies of my opponent to
find an epsilon optimal strategy i can
find it with support that is of the size
logarithmic in that
okay that's a very nice result and very
useful
now remember that regret based dynamics
take that many steps okay which means
now the the where you get based dynamics
work after that many steps to look at
the empirical distribution of what has
happened and give to each one say t
steps each one we give weight one over t
so the support of the qualitative
equilibrium or approximate current
equivalent to get is exactly log n over
epsilon square
up to some constant and again between
here and here there is maybe a constant
of 16 or 32 i mean it's not anything
like zillions okay
so it's quite amazing that those regret
based dynamics which are again very
simple as i tend to say quite stupid you
know
but let's all get into it in fact they
converge as fast as theoretically
possible because you couldn't get
something that would be an epsilon
collected equilibrium faster than that
because that will contra that will not
work with this okay
so remember
there are randomized algorithms
that compute approximate collet
equilibria whose number of queries is
polynomial in n
so
there are two to the power n cells
nevertheless you're going to find the
quality of the equilibrium you are only
going to check a very very tiny
proportion of the cells
of the data of the problem okay
our exact correlated equilibria
we want an exact not just an
approximation exactly how long will it
take how many queries do we need
how about
using deterministic rather than
randomized algorithms okay how long will
it take okay so that was my question
uh we know that randomized algorithms
for approximate called equilibria work
we have something that works very well
how about the other possibilities okay
so here is the table that we want to
fill
namely we want to talk about approximate
correlated and exact correlated and the
algorithm may be randomized or
deterministic and you already have one
cell that says it's polynomial
question what about the other cells okay
so babichenko and barman showed that in
this cell if you want an exact
correlated equilibrium and you want to
do it by a deterministic algorithm you
require
oops
you require exponentially many queries
okay
now is this due to the fact that you
want exact or is it due to the fact that
you want deterministic algorithm answer
both
or either whichever way you want to say
okay so the moment you want exact
related equilibrium
exponential the moment you want you are
going to be deterministic even if you
are satisfied with approximate
equilibrium it's going to be exponential
yes
i'm going to talk about it uh
but okay you asked so i'll i'll answer
now so i won't keep you on your suspense
uh so papa the medium afghan uh
one can look at two ways either the game
is given in a very compact manner which
means it's very easy to know what the
payoffs are you don't need the two to
the power and complexity or
alternatively you can make queries on
mixed strategies so for example you want
to ask what is the payoff where
everybody plays half half i id
now that means taking 2 to the power n
entries in the matrix and averaging 2 to
the power n okay now if you count those
queries then everything becomes nice and
polynomial but you only count pure
queries namely you can go to a cell ask
what the payoff is there okay
okay so
here are the two theorems if you want to
see precise theorems
which is always good
says the following so thor m a let's
start with store m a every deterministic
algorithm that finds even a half
approximate correlated equilibrium so if
half then of course for any epsilon less
than half
in every n person by strategy game by
strategy means they only have two
strategies with pairs that are just zero
one okay
requires uh two to the power
and and this omega by the way i don't
know it's uh n over four and over six
something i mean again it's not uh
brazilians yes i want to say that all
the constants are reasonable constants
that
there is nothing hidden there requires
two to the power n queries in the worst
case okay
and the other theorem says if you want
to find an exact correlated equilibrium
every algorithm that you can think of
whether randomized or deterministic will
require uh now here it's a little more
subtle because uh unlike in the first
theorem we are talking about queries as
well as a support of the output so we
are going to count not just how many
queries we made but if you give me an
answer whose support is very large
that's going to count against you so we
are counting the support plus a number
of queries you can also always assume
the support is small you can always if
you have a large solution in mind you
can subsample it from it not if you want
exact correlated equilibrium
okay that's why here this didn't appear
not that's not exactly why but that
suggests that when so long as you want
approximate then you can do so here we
don't need to include this in the cost
the size of the exact solution is 2 to
the n why is the pro that's why you
measure the no
no it's the number of no it's in fact
it's a number of queries but
if you don't come so open problem okay
drop this is this going to be expansion
and we don't know just the answer size
can be two to the only guy always good
could be could be but that's that not
there's always a short answer right
there's always an answer
that was my question so is there for a
short answer for an exact there is a
basic solution to the basic solution
okay
the question is whether there is an
algorithm that finds it that's an issue
the fact that there are nice yet but
find an algorithm that finds a basic
solution in time that is less or the
number of queries that is less than two
to the power l that's a whole issue
okay do you have an algorithm that has a
few queries but gives you a big answer
is that is that
do we have an algorithm
uh
it seems like a strange
way to phrase it so i mean i was
wondering if you have an example of an
algorithm that uses very few queries but
i don't think we have examples of
algorithms so you only we only prove
negative impossibilities here
the answer can be uniform over the
hypercube
okay that's a short answer that is the
long answer right i see yes but how did
you figure this out from this like it's
puzzling to me that you could know that
something complicated like that is the
answer having not carried all the energy
right so if it's zero error then you
don't need this assumption but the point
is if you allow error in your randomized
algorithm that you're not sure that it's
the right answer then
okay questions about that to norm please
you realize that's not my fault there
okay
yeah this is a short certificate a
positive answer so you're in np
in a sense or is that wrong to put it
this way i mean you have a short story
you require exponential time is this
relative to some complexity assumption
or
a complexity assumption or anything we
just we just count the number of queries
and the support of the data of the the
we're not it's answer an mp the input is
exponential it's 2 to the power n
data the data is n times to the power n
okay so i don't know what np with
respect to what you want to talk about
i mean
the fact that there's a short answer i
thought would be okay
okay
yes going back to theorem b
so you have this condition b
yes okay here is another open question
so it's uh do we have an open question
session today so that i have a few and
there'll be there'll be even more
significant questions at the end but
this is an open question which is uh so
in a moment i'll talk i'll give you the
idea of the proof the game that we build
here the game that we build has pairs
just zero and one here the game that we
beat we need more beats in the payoffs
okay so the number of bits that we need
is something like n we need numbers to
be of the magnitude of two to the power
n as utilities question is is this
correct also with b equal one let's say
so if we restrict ourselves to games
which have pairs only zero one is this
result correct we don't know okay our
construction construction is not easy
there yes i must say but i'll give you
some hints about that anyway so here is
the table again
uh approximate correlated equilibrium
randomized algorithm
number of queries is polynomial in n
everything else exponentially nine
now uh
how about course correlated equilibria
yes everybody is talking about cost
correlated equilibria what's what's
answer
no change because there are only two
actions the moment the game every player
is only two strategies then course
correlated and correlated is exactly the
same so anything bad you say about
correlated immediately translates to
course correlated going to course
correct it doesn't help you suddenly get
something polynomial here okay
uh
very good okay it's written here
okay so whoever asked about
that
okay now what's the idea of the proof so
i'll try
i'll try to give you simple simple again
there are technical details but the idea
is is as follows so once again what's an
action combination is a link to plug
bits okay
so think about think think about the
n-dimensional hypercube what the
vertices are all the two to the power
n-action combinations
okay now an edge that connects two nodes
is what just one bit changes
put on that label that edge with the
regret from moving from here to here or
from here to here one is the minus the
other of course the difference between
payoffs okay now everything you want to
talk about qualitative increments so on
you can express in terms of regrets
nearly payoff differences the pair of
themselves don't matter so you can
always make
you can express everything in terms of
regrets okay so essentially have the
hypercube and each edge is labeled with
a regret now
what's a query a query
you take a node and ask what's the
payoff there or what are the regrets
there and it doesn't matter if you get
all the and regrets that for the price
of one multiplying by n that doesn't
matter it's still polynomial okay
uh now
uh
what happens if the number of queries is
too small so what happens is like
i have an algorithm that's going to make
square is the algorithm makes queries i
provide the answers
and the way i provide the answers i'm
free to provide answers of course once i
set up some regret here if i master the
other node i cannot change i'm committed
so once i tell you what's written on one
edge that's it it's fixed
but i can keep giving you answers in
such a way that there will be no
correlated equilibrium in the area where
you ask questions and the way i do it i
make sure that the regrets are positive
rather than negative quality equilibrium
goes with negative regrets okay it's the
same as negative regrets and what i make
sure that you keep asking questions and
every question you ask i give you
positive regret
okay now i can do it so long as you ask
so many questions of course if you ask
everything i cannot do because every
regret appears once is plus one is minus
but with enough queries i can do that
and
now it's a construction okay i uh i of
course can't get into that read the
paper okay
uh what about theorem sorry
okay what about tower and b turn b is
even is is even more complicated what we
construct is we take a random pass in
the hypercube
and along the path
we make sure that all the regrets are
not all the regrets the sum of the
regrets is positive essentially
it's enough to work with the sum of the
players of the regrets you make sure
that all the gates are positive
only at the end node we we balance it by
making it negative
so the only way to find the correlated
equilibrium you have to find the
endpoint of the path
now if it's a random path good luck in
finding the endpoint okay it's going to
take a very very long time okay
essentially uh you must follow the path
follow the path we must query along the
path because every essentially every n
log n steps there is a complete mixing
and you you even if you know where you
are now and again steps from now you'll
have no idea where it will be you'll be
in a random point in the cube so you
really have to find out where the pass
is again and you have to keep following
the path
uh now it's much more subtle than that
there are various difficulties but
that's essentially the idea of the proof
okay now you see why one bit is not
enough i need i need the regrets to keep
increasing along the path that's why i
need end bids okay
how is this different than bobby
chanko's lower bound
uh how is this so babicenko
is a much simpler version because you
have both exact and deterministic
algorithm and it's again the
construction is similar again you look
in the hypercube and you put the regrets
but that that argument is is relatively
simpler to that but it's the same class
of arguments
which might be
sorry no i know which baby chance but
which baby chance you talk about
the randomized communication complexity
which implies query complexity lower
bounds of course
so any any
we're talking about quality equilibrium
not national
match right right i'm just talking about
he did the same trick with the random
walk on the hypercube right yes he used
this okay
but that was for the nationals the
second one for the second not not from
the call i was i was talking i thought
you were asking about the uh baby check
on barman
paper which is relevant here that that
you're talking about later things
okay
okay now
so now a few more a few more pieces of
information i want to add and tell you
why is this still an inter there is
still a very interesting question here
that is still open okay
so first of all notice
that uh verification so if i give you a
qualitative equilibrium whose support is
of size k
to verify it i need to check k times n
something of the order of k times n or
2n entries
so if you give me a quality equilibrium
small support to verify it it's still
small
okay
very good now if we talk about if we
allow queries for mixed
uh you asked me right okay which is
exactly what
the algorithm of papadimity and raf
garten do with the addition of
kevin and
jing
then you can do everything polynomially
but that requires queries that are much
more sophisticated these queries of what
is the payoff of a mixed strategy which
again it's uh difficult to obtain
uh now suppose i were to take a linear
general linear programming problem of
the same size as correlated equilibrium
problem which is to the power and
unknowns and two n
n constraints doesn't matter yes
how many queries will i need to find an
approximate solution answer
exponential
okay so again
take a general lp problem of identical
size as a quality equilibrium problem
whereas the correlated equilibrium
problem
had a randomized algorithm that gives an
approximate solution with polynomially
many queries that is not true for
general linear programming in fact i
think to do the power n unknowns and
even two constraints is enough to get
that you require exponentially many many
queries coefficients
coefficients yes which are coefficients
are exactly the regrets that's what
enters in that that you have uh
yeah
okay so connected is a special linear
programming problem
because it has this nice property you
can get approximate solutions randomized
algorithm with polynomially many queries
okay
now how is in what way is it special so
let me tell you one way which is special
look at the dual of that problem
do all of that lp turns out the dual
neatly decomposes in and separate
problems that are literally easy okay
now that's really at the basis of the
existence proof of cognitive equilibria
of uh schmeider and myself
that's the basis for those that know
dynamics for what's called uncoupled
dynamics in the world of regret matching
and other heuristics and that's the
basis of the puppet meteorologist
thing
okay so this the fact that the dual is
is
nicely decomposable is a special
property of call it the equilibrium
programming which is not
doesn't hold in general
but now comes a big question why does it
help only for randomized algorithms that
give you approximate solutions and in
none of the other three cells so f4
cells
okay in one of them we get something
that is different than general lp namely
polynomially many queries in the other
three cells it's exponential just like
general general linear programming
problem so why does this structure help
only for randomized algorithms that give
approximate solutions i don't know but i
think it's a it's a very interesting
question to understand really what goes
at work there
okay well the other question is of
course
can you push this to
to approximate nash equilibria so here
is the work that
that uh
baby chance did and other other people
and i think that's that's uh yes i think
i'm on time okay
so that's that's my end
slide
you can read it yourself about queries
any questions
no questions
what do you mean by the last question i
mean it is it's the last question
impossible sorry say again what what do
you mean by the last open question
i mean is
solved or is there no no
there is there is uh
partially solved in terms of what's
called well-supported
approximate measure equilibria i think
that's settled completely by now right
am i right now i'm
almost completely still
not a hundred percent happy but let's
say uh
but but without the well supported i
don't think i don't think anything
useful is known
right
and that's what christos was talking
about at the end of his talk yesterday
that's the best that we know if you know
anything better we'd like to know yes
so
speaking of approximately there are
two notions of approximate parallel
equilibria
one
is
misbehaving
yeah so
okay so we are talking about the one
that you don't like
no the question is how do
no the question is how do you put the
epsilon do you put the absolute
alexander exposed
okay so this epsilon appears exante
which means that that if the uh your
error is normal than epsilon for any
action you cannot improve by more than
epsilon but maybe that action is played
with very small probability or not
conditioning
if you divide then the other will be
much higher okay
so it's epsilon in the sense of linear
programming all inequalities are
satisfied instead of less or equal zero
lesson is called epsilon that's in this
in this sense which in in generating
sense you could say maybe you're not
happy enough on the other hand the
results on dynamics are like this that's
the kind of approximation that one gets
for course that makes sense
maybe it makes more sense
i uh
yeah because you don't have to condition
that's that's correct yeah yeah your
head you add up all those things and uh
yeah you don't want to replace your
average by that yes yes it makes more
sense correct
okay another question
no
okay